[Music]
then i i found him with the scarab
living 20 minutes from our old place i'd
give the show some props for finding a
new way to do exposition via
conversation with the local forger but
why would the forger need this info and
more importantly why would layla be
telling her wait they're gonna have the
forger conveniently be a deep family
friend or some aren't they
also this shot making me momentarily
believe they were shooting this like an
episode of the office all of a sudden i
initially hated it then i loved it then
i hated it again that's why you look so
unhappy to be going home while her
relationship woes are likely a
contributing factor correlation does not
mean causation i'm just saying maybe she
doesn't want to go home because her
parents are constantly nagging her about
the amount of tv she watches and maybe
it's her job and not just a hobby and
maybe they should just get off my back
and let me follow my dreams i mean her
dreams this fortress office is littered
with proof that it's a well forger's
office this 4g of evidence is a great
way to build atmosphere for a tv show
but maybe less great when you're an
actual forger who might want to keep a
low profile i don't
steal they've already been stolen got it
you're just like robin hood that was his
motto right steal from the rich and keep
it for yourself archaeology one big mess
of obsessive bookworms really according
to what i see in the movies and on tv
shows including this one archaeologists
are badass adventurers that'll kick all
the bad guy butt hell even alan grant
almost gutted an eight-year-old with a
raptor claw that one time the passport
goes in the machine one way in this shot
but comes out all turned around and
confused in this shot such experiences
should be reserved for freshman year of
high school and or the first time you
watch a film by david lynch apparently
egyptian passports do specify profession
and i'm just upset my government won't
officially recognize me as a pedantic
[ __ ] 30 seconds of this marvel
property slogo looking at this macguffin
and being confused it's literally
pointing you in the right direction no
interpretation is necessary also it's
not like they need to follow rhodes to
ahmet's tomb so why was scarab maps ever
pointing 90 degrees perpendicular to the
destination and yes this contradicts the
previous sin welcome to the channel i
have lots of questions about this
caravan if they're following ethan's
hawkeye why are they all spread out in
the distance instead of lined up behind
him how are these cars just now coming
up over this hill if they have cars and
communications then why didn't just a
few of them go on the trip and then
signal back after the bps does its magic
this unnaturally occurring trash hurdle
leaves a less cinematic but more
practical option tossing your knife in
the air so we know you're an [ __ ]
who's oddly prepared to start this fight
down a few fingers dancing we're
fighting what we can do you're fighting
but one at a time and never in a way
that poses any real threat to our
protagonist
also mark would be the jets and the
sharks at tv sins
i don't know which one of my friends
needs to hear this but if i'm ever in
close quarters combat with another
individual please do not literally throw
a knife into the situation i lied i know
exactly which one of you needs to hear
this
larry this knife flicking would have
been enough but considering he's punched
in the face mid-lick this means he saw
the punch coming but felt like it was
more important to finish licking than
protect his face he must be a timex
because it takes a licking and keeps on
um licking
and of course the blade is shiny and
clean enough for steven to make an
appearance i swear by this point you
might as well have him see steven in the
reflection of the enemy's eyes not only
is it just as ridiculous it has the
added benefit of being even less
thematically subtle mark's only a few
steps behind these guys when the shot
cuts then we see that he's climbed up to
the second story of a building for some
reason which was not helpful because
he's further away from catching them now
but it's still cool because he gets to
jump off this truck but whatever caused
him to take this alternate path was
probably cool as well and we don't get
to see it stan what did you do i swear
that wasn't me okay fine but you've been
in the knife reflection right you saw
what happened every other time you're in
some random reflection you seem to know
what's going on so why not this time and
honestly shouldn't both of you be in
there if there's a third moon child
then pull him back you script-filling
piece of plot tension if you had time to
say no kid in another second before he
cut the scarf with a knife you had time
to yank it there is always time to yank
it i didn't do any of this me neither so
neither of them was in control of their
body seems like an important and
concerning development but i guess mark
and steven have agreed to table that for
another episode keep digging
no matter what happens keep digging no
matter what what if they hit stone what
if they hit oil and up from the ground
comes some bubbling crude what if you
tell them to stop digging what then mr
bossypants before a meeting of the anya
a portal presents itself anywhere that's
why we named it the portal of ultimate
convenience aren't you coming with us
writers chose this cryptic non-answer
instead of i will suddenly and without
warning possess your body so stay loose
and don't eat any spicy food oh my days
we're inside title of my sex tape she
says it was not so long ago konchu
enjoyed hathor's melodies hieroglyphs or
it didn't happen but manipulate the sky
again and we will imprison you in stone
this is a weird and oddly specific place
to draw the line so it's pretty wild
that this is the exact thing konchu does
later in the show we decided long ago we
did not wish to meddle in the affairs of
man not enough proof but i'm pretty sure
it's written somewhere that all new
marvel properties must include some
version of the prime directive as a way
of explaining where all the characters
that could have helped were during the
whole thanos debacle and i think it's
safe to say no one cares anymore let us
summon the accused i love how gods with
unimaginable powers still do old school
trials when they aren't blocking out the
sun or creating insta portals that know
exactly where the other avatars are i
shall smite the earth in the inhabitants
thereof and also if the prosecution
would call your first witness please
he's a deceiver
that's it that's the depth of konchu's
argument when earlier he said all kings
against
i thought we were about to see konchu go
full arthur kirkland from injustice for
all instead he went frido pendejo from
idiocracy i have no idea how many
personalities he must possess what does
that have to do with anything just
because conscious avatar has mental
health issues doesn't mean conscious
himself is untrustworthy this is
secondhand ad hominem and i can't
believe the prosecuting attorney hasn't
objected yet he has committed no offense
this matter is concluded [ __ ] what
did you even look at any evidence do any
exploration of the facts this court of
the gods makes the u.s judicial system
look ultra competent in comparison and
that's quite a feat mark there is
another way of course there is i'm
looking for sen food sarcophagus see
this is the problem with the gig economy
it's not enough to just be a black
market information vendor you also need
a side hustle as a juice broker just to
make ends meet i hope you like attention
i'm not sure which is sillier that mark
would ask for sinfu's sarcophagus in
public or that layla just happens to
find him here did the fed write this
script because with every dumb or
convenient choice my interest rates are
certainly lowering i've never really
been able to just talk about
everything summon the skip preserving
history is a responsibility i take very
seriously almost as seriously as my
responsibility to install random mirror
pillars in my courtyard in case they
might be needed for any totally non-plot
related reasons
please just let steven out before you
blow this maybe a conversation you
should have settled before saying weird
things like this in front of your
already suspicious host you think also
i'm no expert in the preservation of
ancient artifacts but i learned a hard
lesson that one time i left my copy of
descent from xanadu out in the sun too
long so i'm pretty sure the open
sarcophagus of senpu it's not the type
of thing you store outside in a
transparent glass pyramid with
convenient ceiling mirrors especially
not in egypt
what
it's legit i don't care so much the name
dropping the student walken feels a bit
like an attempt to establish ancient
egyptian artifact street cred if there
is such a thing but i do care that the
show doesn't at least hint at why this
word sounds german do you really think
i'm an idiot honestly no one knows
what's going on in the scene right now
let alone what you're thinking mark was
folding pieces of cloth he found in the
sarcophagus before you interrupted and
we had no idea where that was going so
you're holding all the cards and now
would be a great time to enlighten us it
appears we have a concerned third party
yeah of course we do is this show going
for a record number of scenes in which
the protagonists and antagonists meet in
don't actually confront each other do it
summon the suit conscious completely
making sense here but why does mark even
need to be told this if you had an
ass-kicking invincibility suit at your
beck and call aren't you calling that
[ __ ] down the second a gun appears what
just happened and how is that helpful
judging by the fact that this is what my
burrito looks like after putting it in
for 30 minutes instead of three i'm
gonna assume he just microwaved the
sarcophagus to destroy the star map but
if that was the plan he did a terrible
job at it since they're able to tape it
back together later why is scene sure
summon the suit now after arthur has
gone away show can kiss my full moon
knight
okay that was cool buy me some time i
can do that sometime you're about to
fling the bullets stuck to your cape
with enough pinpoint accuracy to take
out eight hinge persons i think you can
just in this thing now and then layla
can take all the time she wants this
scene illustrates just how difficult it
is to land the double midair kick i
applaud the attempt but you missed that
second kick and you'll be penalized
accordingly give me the body mark
equipped only with overconfidence in his
ability to handle this life or death
situation steven interrupts another
fight sequence i think the goal here was
comic relief but i also think it's safe
to say that no one is laughing that's
all just like chill the f out and talk
for a second
the body
take the body
okay now i'm laughing
i've removed my protective face shroud
so you can see how seriously i'm calling
out your name don't worry i'll put it
back on here in a second when i start
fighting the guys who have all the
sudden pause for this intense moment
taping ancient cloth in the desert all
right go ahead you're in you really had
to rip the mirror off the vehicle walk
away from the light source and dump the
already tenuous tape into the sand
before doing this
this this was the thing they were having
such difficulty reassembling i've seen
children put more complicated puzzles
together well um
actually steven just uttered a literal
um actually and i'm pretty sure we've
got those trademarked by this point so
here's a sin and you'll be hearing from
our lawyers disney so unless we know
exactly what the sky looked like on that
date so the star map only worked on one
night why the [ __ ] would anyone make a
map that only works for one night i can
turn back the night sky how it will come
at a cost let me guess the cost will be
a way to conveniently create plot
tension and stakes for the rest of the
season maybe the invincible moon night
won't be able to moon night anymore am i
close do what i do but do it while
standing in front of me and not being
able to see me because i'm taller and it
will look more cinematic that way the
universe survives this so let me get
this straight the mere seconds that
konchu and konchu jr have been spinning
the night sky all the other avatars got
the message portaled here and got set up
for this imprisonment spell
this show continues to play glass sounds
with every step hero takes but shouldn't
that glass be embedded in his foot by
this point or crushed to the point of
not making noise or does he have to stop
every couple of hours at a glass station
to fill up
i'm tired of this grandpa it's too damn
bad you keep digging
i've already got my name picked out
lord rupert everton
i'm a uh a shipping merchant who raises
fancy dogs no he's uh he's probably
going to get himself killed running
around cairo
what is the five fingers side of the
face
what
slap
oh my cabbages
so
what about the other gods so they're
just gonna
stand by and allow somebody to unleash
on it they know
they just don't care
keep digging
no matter what happened
i must admit i do not miss the sound of
that voice
but speak old master to the point and
the truth
shall set you free
this is not about my feelings i'm not
the one on trial here you're out of
order you're out of order the whole
trial is out of order he's going to kill
millions trust me are you seriously
talking about trades
humanity's savage nature will inevitably
lead to global annihilation
so in order to save this planet
i had to trick it for the greatest
practical joke
in human history
[Music]
[Applause]